this episode is sponsored by blinkist
blinkist takes all of the need to know
information from thousands of
non-fiction books and condenses it down
into just 15 minutes and you can go to
blinkist.com microcosmos to learn more
sometimes james our master of
microscopes likes to go through his
samples with the lowest magnification
objective looking at the organisms as
they're floating in a petri dish so that
he can see everything from a distance
and get a sense for what mysteries await
him when he zooms in
during one of his recent petri dish
scans he found this stunning ciliate
autofluorescein a whole crayon box's
worth of colors under our combination uv
blue green and red light and when you
switch to white light the ciliate is
still quite colorful maybe not the same
fluorescent rainbow it was before but
full of varied shades of purple like a
blueberry bush ripening in summer but
the ciliate didn't seem to be doing so
well in the petri dish so for james to
be able to take this video with the
clarity and focus it needs he first had
to move the ciliate to a slide a
procedure that is quite normal and safe
for most microbes but for our already
dying ciliate it proved to be too much
as soon as it hit the slide it burst
open and all of those little blueberries
came pouring slowly out as well
the cilia died too fast for us to be
able to identify it there was just too
much damage erasing all clues to its
identity but the ciliate wasn't the only
organism in the video
those round bits of purple were once
alive as well and what remains of their
color provides more than enough
information to identify them
these are purple sulfur bacteria and
ciliates are not the only danger they
face now its biggest foe is something
even more pedestrian than that
you see something you need to know about
the purple sulfur bacteria is that it's
a bit of a contrarian specifically when
it comes to photosynthesis
[Music]
now what do you think of when you hear
the word photosynthesis you might think
of trees and plants and leaves or since
you're here with us right now on this
journey maybe you're thinking of algae
and cyanobacteria and euglena what most
of us are probably imagining could boil
down to the color green lots and lots of
green
and for good reason chlorophyll the
pigment that absorbs light and kicks off
the reactions that drive photosynthesis
is green
and that green has come to dominate the
world that we live in
but there is another world too
inhabited by purple sulfur bacteria and
these purple sulfur bacteria can also do
photosynthesis
they have bacterial chlorophyll but they
also contain carotenoids pigments that
create colors ranging from red to purple
and that help the bacteria harvest light
and get protection from the bacteria's
primary foe oxygen
but wait you might be saying to yourself
how can an organism be photosynthetic
and so afraid of oxygen doesn't
photosynthesis create oxygen
and yes
you would be correct
most of the time the most common form of
photosynthesis in our world is oxygenic
photosynthesis it makes oxygen this is
what happens in all of those plants and
cyanobacteria where energy from light
sets off a chain reaction involving
water and carbon dioxide the end result
is a sugar for the organism and oxygen
for the atmosphere
that is the world we live in a world
where oxygen is a necessity and readily
supplied by photosynthesis but purple
sulfur bacteria contrarian that it is
prefers the worlds in this world that do
not have oxygen our samples for example
came from the sediments at the bottom of
palms and puddles places where oxygen
does not arrive consumed as it has been
by the organisms above
down at the bottom of their palms the
purple sulfur bacteria do their own form
of photosynthesis called an oxygenic
photosynthesis and they're not the only
organisms to prefer this oxygen-less
approach to making their own food
confusingly enough there are also green
sulfur bacteria and purple non-sulfur
bacteria both of which also do an
oxygenic photosynthesis though sometimes
with their own twists
for the purple sulfur bacteria the key
ingredient is
well it's sulfur you may not think of
sulfur as an essential element to life
but that's because we have bodies born
out of a world full of oxygen but in the
stratified world of the purple sulfur
bacteria the void left by a lack of
oxygen instead is filled by sulfur so
where a normal photosynthetic organism
would consume water to drive their
photosynthesis they consume sulfurous
chemicals like hydrogen sulfide which
you might recognize from its rotten egg
smell and when they're done making their
own food the byproduct of their
endeavors is not oxygen it is sulfur and
because they live in an environment that
is constantly changing purple sulfur
bacteria are able to store up sulfurous
molecules for whatever the microbial
equivalent of a rainy day is all of this
sulfur-based photosynthesis makes purple
sulfur bacteria something better than
just contrarian
they are a good neighbor helping to
consume hydrogen sulfide that might be
toxic in clearing out the waters for
their upstairs neighbors that require a
more oxygenated environment to survive
though that role that place is a good
neighbor is based on the ecological
neighborhoods we have today where lawns
of oxygen give way to lawns of sulfur
that neighborhood has gone through some
changes though and there was a time
before oxygen's dominance where purple
silver bacteria were less of a
contrarian than they are now
in 2005 researchers uncovered
photosynthetic pigments fossilized and
preserved in rocks that are more than a
billion years old lying in a large basin
in australia
these fossils suggested that purple
sulfur bacteria may have existed in
ancient oceans during a period when
oxygen was still rising in the world but
had not come to take over the oceans the
fossils suggest an ancient world that
would be
unrecognizable to us
in fact we probably wouldn't be able to
survive there but as the world has
shifted the purple sulfur bacteria has
found a way to shift with it to make
space for themselves even as new
neighbors move in
but of course those other organisms
don't seem to be looking to thank the
purple sulfur bacteria anytime soon i
mean who needs a neighbor when you can
have a meal instead
thank you for coming on this journey
with us as we explore the unseen world
that surrounds us we'd like you to know
that we're going to be taking a short
break from uploading for the next couple
of weeks but we will be back soon with
brand new videos if you'd like to keep
up with exactly when we'll be back with
a new episode make sure to follow us on
twitter at journey2micro and before we
go we need to thank blinkist for
sponsoring today's episode now after
watching this video we hope you would
feel pretty comfortable saying that you
know what purple sulfur bacteria are but
let me ask you a question do you know
what a lexicographer is
well
i could not hear your answer but i'm
going to go ahead and assume that some
of you said no a lexicographer is a
person who writes dictionaries it's a
very cool and interesting job that
involves way more time and research than
you might initially think and in the
book word by word author corey stamper
explains how there is no right or wrong
when it comes to grammar usage and
reveals the three criteria that a word
must meet in order to be considered for
the dictionary you can find out more
about this fascinating profession by
checking out word by word on blinkist
blinkist is an app that takes the best
insights and need to know information
from over 3 000 non-fiction books and
condenses them down into just 15 minutes
that you can read or listen to it can be
hard to find the time to sit down and
learn more but with blinkist you can
explore their massive library of books
and catalogs like self-help business
science and history and if you're one of
the first 100 people to sign up today at
blinkist.com microcosmos you can get
free unlimited access for seven days and
you'll also get 25 off if you decide to
get a full membership click the link in
the description to start your free seven
day trial and now you are seeing some
names on your screen these are our
patreon patrons these are the people who
make it possible for us to continue
diving into this bizarre and lovely
world finding new intriguing stories to
tell you about all of the different ways
that life
works and has worked on our planet so if
you want to thank anybody for this
lovely episode these are the people to
thank and i also want to thank them
personally y'all are great thank you for
being a part of what we do if you want
to see more from our master of
microscopes james weiss check out jam
and germs on instagram and if you want
to see more from us there's always a
subscribe button somewhere nearby
[Music]